[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días sean france24 este es
un magacín informativo 100 dedicado al
continente africano mi nombre es liliana
valencia que damos una mirada en
profundidad a los hechos de actualidad
de la semana en la cuna de la humanidad
nuevo secuestro masivo en nigeria esta
vez los hechos ocurrieron en la ciudad
de jan jefe donde un grupo de hombres
armados irrumpió en un centro educativo
y raptó a 317 niñas en el segundo
secuestro masivo en el país durante las
últimas semanas
ghana se convirtió en el primer país del
mundo en recibir vacunas contra el cubil
19 por medio del mecanismo kóvacs 600
mil dosis llegan al aeropuerto de accra
la capital y se espera que otros países
de asia occidental reciban lotes en los
próximos días y varios países africanos
trabajan en la transformación de
desechos plásticos en material de
construcción en costa de márfil una
empresa colombiana construye aulas con
el apoyo de unicef
iniciamos entonces con la información in
africa siete días y empezamos en nigeria
donde 317 niñas fueron raptadas por un
grupo de hombres armados que rompió en
una escuela en la ciudad de jan jefe el
secuestro masivo de escolares se ha
convertido en una constante en el país
en la última semana bandas criminales
habían secuestrado a otras 42 personas
entre ellas 27 estudiantes que ya fueron
liberados entretanto la familia de las
niñas deja nieve esperan noticias y los
resultados del operativo de rescate
puesto en marcha por las autoridades
la educación está en peligro en nigeria
las tengo miedo de volver a la escuela
por lo que pasó pero volveré si el
gobierno aborda la inseguridad pupitres
vacíos y ropa abandonada son los restos
del internado femenino de ciencias en
javier en el noroeste del país luego de
que hombres armados secuestraran a 317
alumnas durante la noche del jueves
sam's y ya es una de las jóvenes que
logró escapar de sus captores su como en
las sequías nixon con blooming vinieron
tres grupos el del medio irrumpió en
nuestro albergue luego algunas empezamos
a correr hacia el baño y otras nos
escondimos debajo de la cama ellos nos
pedían a todos que saliéramos nos
insultaban diciendo que éramos nosotros
los que comíamos la comida del gobierno
nos pidieron que saliéramos de nuestros
escondites disparando al aire todos
teníamos miedo y gritaba mucho
es el tercer ataque a un colegio en
nigeria en menos de tres meses sucesos
que han revivido los traumáticos
recuerdos de las niñas de chivos
secuestradas por los yihadistas de boko
haram en 2014 los padres de las jóvenes
esperan resignados noticias de la misión
de rescate que intenta localizar a las
niñas y critican al gobierno por su
ineficiencia
hacemos un llamamiento al gobierno debe
hacer lo mejor para que esas niñas
vuelvan y para que garantice la
seguridad a los ciudadanos nigerianos
porque está dando vueltas hijos isis
guaira o el gobierno tiene que hacer
algo más fuerte que antes
los asesinatos la violencia sexual y los
secuestros masivos para pedir rescates
han aumentado drásticamente en el norte
de nigeria unos ataques que atentan
contra el derecho a la educación de los
estudiantes nigerianos en una región
donde el 80% de la población vive en la
extrema pobreza
ganar recibido el primer lote de vacunas
distribuidas por el mecanismo de
cooperación internacional kóvacs este
proceso liderado por la organización
mundial de la salud fue creado para
garantizar el acceso pronto de los
países en vías de desarrollo a las
vacunas contra el kobe 19 tras ocho
meses de planificación cual se entregó
600.000 dosis de la vacuna de
astrazéneca a este país de áfrica
occidental
kóvacs ya es una realidad palpable
hoy estamos en el aeropuerto
internacional de kotoka en accra ghana y
es realmente un momento histórico
estamos muy felices de recibir el primer
lote de vacunas contra el kobe 19 a
través de kóvacs
600.000 dosis de la vacuna desarrollada
por la universidad de oxford y
astrazéneca aterrizaron en ghana
provenientes de india donde fueron
fabricadas representan la inmunización
de 300.000 trabajadores de la salud y
personas de alto riesgo en este país
africano que empezará su campaña de
vacunación el 2 de marzo son vacunas
aseguradas por el mecanismo de
cooperación internacional kóvacs una
iniciativa liderada por la o ms de la
cual dependen la mayoría de los países
pobres para combatir a cabalidad el kobe
hoy culminan muchos meses de planeación
e investigación negociación y
coordinación pero es sólo el principio
todavía tenemos mucho trabajo para hacer
realidad nuestra visión de una
vacunación equitativa
y es que el proceso de compra y
administración de las vacunas es de todo
menos equitativo mientras la unión
europea y eeuu han asegurado la
adquisición de cerca de 3 mil 800
millones de dosis regiones como áfrica o
américa latina' no suman ni siquiera una
tercera parte de esta cifra
precisamente kóvacs quiere equilibrar la
balanza y proveer a los países de
ingresos bajos y medios suficientes
vacunas como para inmunizar al 20 por
ciento de su población para hacerlo
necesita al menos dos mil millones de
dosis de los fármacos desarrollados por
el momento ha adquirido más de la mitad
una carrera contrareloj para asegurar
una inmunización justa
un informe amnistía internacional
denuncia crímenes de guerra cometidos en
la región del tigre de etiopía a finales
de noviembre el informe denuncia la
masacre de al menos 240 civiles que
salpican las fuerzas armadas etíopes y
eritreos veamos el informe
en sudán cientos de miles de refugiados
viven apiñados en campos tras tener que
huir de sus casas en la región de tigre
al norte de etiopía tigre se ha visto
afectada por intensos combates desde
noviembre de 2020 según un reciente
informe de amnistía internacional
cientos de personas fueron asesinadas en
una masacre que tuvo lugar en la ciudad
de aksu me el pasado año lo que
encontramos es que ha habido bombardeos
indiscriminados de civiles en axum el 28
y 29 de noviembre
ofertar amnistía ha afirmado que hay
abrumadoras evidencias de estos crímenes
cometidos mientras las tropas etíopes y
sus aliados eritreos reconquistaba en la
ciudad atrapen era lo que ocurrió en
axum es espantoso la cantidad el sistema
y la naturaleza de los asesinatos la
manera en que ejecutaron a la gente es
horrible y no sólo eso ni siquiera les
permitieron recoger a los muertos y
enterrarlos hasta más de 48 horas el
primer ministro etíope había cnet lanzó
una ofensiva a gran escala en tigre el
pasado 4 de noviembre después de acusar
al frente de liberación del pueblo de
tigre él
de atacar una base militar
mete claro la victoria después de que
las tropas gubernamentales capturaron la
capital me quedé a finales de noviembre
pero el tlf prometió seguir luchando y
sigue habiendo enfrentamientos en la
región el complicado acceso a esa zona
hace difícil confirmar las denuncias de
violencia vamos al norte del continente
porque después de un cese las
manifestaciones a causa de la pandemia
los integrantes del movimiento
prodemocracia gira que en argelia
volvieron a tomarse las calles de
diferentes ciudades para exigir un
verdadero cambio en el gobierno los
manifestantes exigen un estado civil y
no militar como el que ha liderado el
país norteafricano desde su
independencia de francia en 1962
[Aplausos]
gritando el pueblo quiere la
independencia siento se tomaron las
calles en argelia con la esperanza de
reiniciar las manifestaciones semanales
a favor de la democracia
hoy es el regreso de irak argelia libre
y democrática
conocido como el movimiento dirá que sus
manifestantes ayudaron a expulsar al
presidente abdelaziz buteflika del poder
en el 2019 su candidatura a un quinto
mandato fue lo que provocó una
indignación generalizada
sin embargo las protestas fueron
suspendidas por la pandemia de
coronavirus con la celebración el lunes
del segundo aniversario del movimiento
prodemocracia muchos están ansiosos por
reanudar las protestas
no es un juego de ajedrez buteflika ha
sido reemplazado por tf1
'queremos desarraigar a esta pandilla
que se vayan todos y consigamos un nuevo
país
los manifestantes dicen que las reformas
propuestas por el gobierno actual no van
lo suficientemente lejos están
presionando por una reforma radical y
menos influencia del ejército que ha
estado en una posición de poder desde
que argelia obtuvo su independencia de
francia en 1962
en costa marfil específicamente en
abiyán se producen en trescientas
toneladas de residuos plásticos al día y
sólo el 5% se reciclan y se actuó la
idea de convertir este flagelo en una
oportunidad y en asociación con una
industrial colombiano está construyendo
escuelas con ladrillos plásticos
reciclados
plástico en cada esquina abiyán se está
ahogando en un mar de residuos sólidos
en este vertedero ciudadanos trabajan
clasificando los desechos y recogiendo
plástico es su forma de sustento si en
los últimos meses sus condiciones han
mejorado
ahora hacemos parte de una empresa y
francamente es muy interesante es bueno
es muy bonito los ingresos de estas
mujeres se han más que duplicado desde
que entregan plástico recolectado a solo
un cliente la empresa colombiana
conceptos plásticos inaugurada el año
pasado la planta transformar residuos
plásticos en materiales de construcción
es todo el plástico que hay aquí ahora
lo vamos a triturar y lo vamos a
diversificar para poder usarlo ahora en
nuestro proceso de fabricación
[Música]
después del proceso el resultado son
columnas y ladrillos de plástico un
material económico más resistente y
ligero que los tradicionales toda la
producción está destinada a unicef para
la construcción de aulas y escasez de
aulas en costa de marfil es una de las
razones por la que los niños no van a la
escuela
faltan salones y los que hay están muy
llenos en este distrito de abiyán justo
al lado del antiguo edificio ha surgido
una nueva sala pero también niñas la
principal ventaja según este profesor es
que el plástico aísla el calor mejor que
el concreto 21 ratos de la clase y fue
cuando entramos en el aula hace menos
calor a diferencia de los edificios
normales hay aire estamos cómodos cuando
damos lecciones donde formales los
screen 12 distorsión yo q unicef que ha
construido 61 aulas de plástico
reciclado en todo el país y cada mes se
construyen más
y es que el líder de este proyecto de
construcción de aulas con material de
construcción reciclado es un colombiano
se trata de oscar méndez cofundador de
conceptos plásticos previamente hablamos
con él y nos contó sobre su objetivo de
fortalecer y ofrecer soluciones al
problema del plástico entre áfrica y
américa latina
y estamos muy felices de contarles que
hemos iniciado operaciones en costa de
márfil no solo con una planta de
transformación sino con todo nuestro
modelo de negocio y la metodología que
hemos llevado a partir de nuestra
experiencia en colombia
ahora estamos empoderando a mujeres en
cuanto a la recolección para que hagan
parte de nuestra cadena de suministro
significando un poco sus condiciones de
vida entrenando personas para que
trabajen en nuestra planta de producción
y entrenando equipos de construcción
para que hagan los montajes de las aulas
que se están construyendo en costa de
mágico
vemos con mucha felicidad que podemos
llevar buenas experiencias
latinoamericanos al continente africano
y estamos en búsqueda de abrir nuestra
operación en algunos otros países para
también tener todos esos impactos que
siempre nos ha caracterizado ambientales
económicos y más aún sociales
y finalizamos también con música que nos
llega desde colombia donde seis artistas
afrodescendientes se unieron para crear
un proyecto llamado resistencia
ellas cantan contra la discriminación
hacia la mujer negra en américa latina y
resaltan la herencia africana que sigue
viva en esta región con las imágenes de
su más reciente videoclip y esta buena
música nos despedimos en este capítulo
de áfrica siete días pero ustedes pueden
continuar con más también en france 24
punto com quédense aquí nos vemos más
adelante con más información entradas 24
y por qué
[Aplausos]
su valiente alegre
[Música]
dónde
si vienes a maltratarme camino con paso
firme levantado
mostrando la resistencia de respuesta
[Música]